george mcgill of social chain has joined
me so what we're talking about today
George mental models almost like recipes
for like regular decision making if you
can imagine that your consciousness is
like a the OS like mental models are
just various sort of apps that you like
plug in for like various decisions or
situations that you find yourself in and
so on Instagram you're scrolling through
artificial lives that are meant to make
yours look worse
whereas walking around the hospital
you're looking at real lives who would
do anything to change like positions
with you but see if we come I left an
eight out of ten when I'm on Instagram
I'm looking at ten out of ten lives and
I'm contrasting my 8 out 10 of a 10 out
of 10 and feeling the minus to the
gaming industry is worth more than the
music and entertainment industry
combined which is crazy right so I'm
immediately thinking the gaming industry
have a greater understanding of human
psychology better than anybody on the
planet can we do signal versus noise so
signal versus noise like how you go
about establishing what's true and
what's going to be gone tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen welcome back
George McGill of social chain has joined
me Hawaii I'm not too bad how are you
very good thank you George Mack on
Twitter
no no Twitter still not transferred
across on Instagram no no no need to I
like it so what we're talking about
today George um so I guess we is more
like a theme of what we've been chatting
about for like the last six to nine
months right which is like mental models
and how you sort of interpret that it's
like up to you like I particularly got
it from like Charlie Munger like navarre
ever can a few other thinkers about like
almost like recipes for like regular
decision making if you can imagine that
your consciousness is like a like the OS
like mental models are just various sort
of apps that you like plug in for like
various decisions or situations that you
find yourself in and it's almost like
this I think Charlie mode cause like a
latticework like from all the big like
disciplines whether that's like physics
over that business whether that's
microeconomics because what a lot of
people do will just specialize and go
okay I learn biology and then that's all
I do and they just go deep on that
subject whereas that whole like Tim
Ferriss strategy of taking the the 10%
that covers 90% of it from biology like
memories like evolution whether it's
homeostasis and then going into like
microeconomics and looking at like game
theory like race to the bottom taking
all these strategies and then almost
trying to apply them instead of having
to deal with like the overwhelm of
everyday life that's how I sort of
interpret it but then I now it's much
looser and just anything where it's like
an analogy that helps me like explain
things is really really useful totally
so you introduced me to mental models
when I first came in here actually to do
a the podcast with the guys from social
minds yeah and we sat down and you took
me through it it was the first time I'd
heard of it Charlie Munger appears to be
kind of like hey Charlie its patient
zero for it yes yes a charlie is less
lesser-known but he is Warren Buffett's
business partner who obviously the guy
who runs Berkshire Hathaway so he's
wealth richest man in the world
yeah fourth official Ritchie's mind
aware there's a lot of like unofficial
people out so Marco that's yeah so yeah
he's Warren Buffett's business partner
and he's sort of been obsessed for his
career of taking these ideas from the
big disciplines that's where I
originally like got it from so like one
my favorite one from like Charlie was
like just in version which was like this
is like quite a nice introduction this
is probably the most simple one as you
can sample Apple I regularly yeah
example a mental model right so in
version is almost comes from mathematics
when you try and reverse a problem on
its head so for example the best example
I always use because it's so woolly
trying to figure out is put it in
versions particularly useful for those
woolly conversations or those woolly
questions so like happiness right what
is how do I become happy i people spend
their whole lives like exploring that
question what's this purpose i've got a
fire like do i have to go to a spiritual
retreat in india and sit and meditate -
yes but instead Munger would just say
you just flip it on its head and go how
would I make a happy person depressed
and it's like quite easy the answers
there then right so first thing you do
is mess with their mess with their sleep
schedule like completely flip it on the
head have them sleep in leh have them
sleeping like all four have blue light
coming in so you do that second one you
do is mess with their nutrition like you
have them eating awful food you'd
immediately isolate them from the
friends you'd put them in a [ __ ] job and
you just take away any form of meaning
or hobbies from their life so you look
at those five things there if you avoid
all of those five you've basically
achieved happiness right you're 95% the
way there so instead of like manga
basically looks at ours instead of
trying to seek excellence just focus on
avoiding stupidity he says that's the
success of his career like he's never
gone out to seek like excellence him and
Warren it's just always avoiding
stupidity so myself and my business
partner Darren say something similar
about Club promo that were not
fantastically talented club promoters
we've just made 10 years of mistakes
that we've only ever made once okay
because it is really technically only a
mistake as far as I'm concerned if you
make it twice I give it a strategic
learning experience that you choose not
to learn from it's kind of your fault
the first time there happens you like
how well if you didn't
you didn't know you can't know what you
don't know so let's use look at that
clip promo is a good example right so I
said I was starting my own night out
it's often very good to think about what
would make a successful night out so
you'd be like thinking about getting a
DJ here in getting XY z-- edit but
instead you should start from what would
like make this go like absolutely or
free like whether it's how you want to
get your health and safety stuff in
order right so focus on the senior
management to expensive drinks poor
service bad smell bad DJ yeah she's that
whole quite like show me where I'm gonna
die so I'll never go there yeah that's
the key and I was using this like this
is one of the things I've about meant
and what was it that he actually have
like real world like applicability so as
thinking like as a did on like a Sunday
evening just like reviewing stuff
because I'm 25 next month so like almost
50% away from my 20s I'm like what do I
want the rest of my twenties to look
like and that was just one of those
overwhelming questions like I couldn't
answer so I was like huh what do I
definitely not want to go to so older
cuz I rest on my phone I think it up so
I was thinking like what mistakes do I
see people make in their 20s and what
like could I actively go out and avoid
so the 7 that I came up with was like
number one to avoid comfort in your
twenties because if you're comfortable
in your 20s then you're just like
absolutely screwed to like hanging
around or working with people who I
don't admire 3 doing easy things and
like avoiding building like career moats
that you can just compound and iterate
off the back off for neglecting or like
abusing your health 5 gaining
liabilities in debt 6 toxic
relationships 7 feedback less
environments and I realized if I avoid
all of those 7 no matter what I do if I
just keep on focusing avoiding all those
7 it's almost impossible to fail because
by the very nature these are all the
things that's going to lead to failure
so instead of just setting some girl
where I want to earn X or I want to be
ABC I'm just focusing on avoiding those
7 because I think it's so easy for
people to get caught up in like chasing
this big big goal and forgetting like
the dogs that are at the door that are
coming to eat them so focus on those 7
like particularly like a great example
that is the toxic relationships one
might have thought about this one quite
a lot because you almost got the two
categories of toxic relationships right
you've got
the toxic about the cliche one that you
see on the news or an episode of the
bill of like somebody being like
physically abusive right but the one
that's I'd say affects people way more
than much more like passive ones that
people like see like like sleep their
way into so we're not sleep their way
into that's the wrong hood there but
maybe that's how you get there as well
right but that you every day
it just gets a bit well that's 5,000
codes and you start change it which gets
onto another mental model right so you
didn't have like contrasting you know
Charlie Munger and it's called the
psychology of human misjudgment where
he's talking about the frog in boiling
water you know the famous and it don't
where you put a frog in boiling water it
jumps out you put the frog in cold water
and slowly heat it up and it will just
sit there till it dies and he says at
the end of it because I don't know if
that's like a a true thing about frogs
but it's but it's true of every business
person that he's ever met and he's doing
elite business people so that's power of
contrast power of contrast yeah so
that's almost like I never mention water
right so you look at contrast I would
say contrast is probably the most
important thing for like human happiness
you you can see everywhere like the the
hedonic treadmill like the fact that we
live in the best time ever to be alive
and people are still miserable I find
that fascinating like why is that so I
spoke to professor Rick Hanson New York
Times bestseller writer of hardwiring
happiness and his most recent book
resilience and what I came to about that
was I thought that if you take Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and you look at
Paleolithic man your grand great great
great great great two times 100
grandfather 100,000 years ago ten
thousand years ago the bottom of his
pyramid would have been a lot more
poorly serviced safety food shelter
warmth hydration all of that sort of
stuff the bottom end would have been a
lot more poorly service but because he
was doing exactly what he needed his
attention was his to command the top end
of the pyramid was looked after quite
well whereas I think what's happened now
is we flipped out on its head and you
have very high degree of comfort most
people in
first century in the Western world are
not super concerned about their warmth
and the safety the food they comfort all
of that's being looked after which leads
to this existential crisis that's self
referential because the top has now been
serviced less previously you you would
have been your job it would have been a
job for life your job might have been a
craft or a trade that you could have
taken some pride in flow from me higher
cheeks egg me higher like alludes to
that yeah deep work from Cal Newport
also alludes to that there's
neurologically Milan creates around
neurons that are continually firing
neurons that fire together wire together
so in terms of the neuroscience behind
it it makes sense psychologically it
makes sense because you are able to feel
some inherent degree of aptitude and and
prowess and finesse in doing something
difficult that's challenging and
worthwhile and overcoming it and then
that just generally in terms of what
that says about you socially as well
people think are you you are adding
value because you have that whereas in
the modern world now a lot of knowledge
workers have no feedback mechanism like
you wake up you had 100 emails you go to
bed you've done 100 but received 103
I've got a hundred three emails you like
did I do a good job did I do a bad job I
have no idea so I think that in the 21st
century one of the problems is that we
don't have an effective feedback
mechanism for when work has been done
for a lot of people in a lot of jobs
like if you're a Smith or a carpenter or
a farmer or anyone you know when the
fields been plowed you know when the
wheels been made you know when the car's
been fixed there's an inherent amount of
satisfaction that comes with that and
the same thing would have come from if
your total your hierarchy of needs began
and ended with keeping your family safe
and having an aphid to eat once you've
achieved that there you go that's your
self-actualization has been made because
that's how high your hierarchy of needs
goes however when you have looked after
that you start to look at things that
are actually a lot more difficult for
you to reach so that was my hypothesis
about why we have the
in the modern world that makes a lot of
sense I think like from an element of
like contrast about how we actually
utilize contrast in particular I thought
I had a real word this is where it all
came from I wrote to a thread on this
like last year it was a sulphate
hospital which is like a couple miles
away from where we are now and had a
family member that was ill so literally
for five six days of the week I'd go in
after work and go there and it going
back to inversion before it's like an
inverse Instagram feed right and so when
Instagram you're scrolling through
artificial lives that are meant to make
yours look worse
whereas walking around the hospital
you're looking at real lives who would
do anything to change like positions
with you
because I look at my life so let's save
me some wild life's an eight out of ten
when I'm on Instagram I'm looking at ten
out of ten lives and I'm contrasting my
eight out of ten with a ten out of ten
and feeling the minus two whereas when
you walk around the hospital ward where
people are dying your contrasting your
eight out of ten with you could argue
like a zero out of ten or one out of ten
you told me I think it was around
exactly the same time that you
recommended I read the last Highlander
by Alistair Urquhart yeah forgotten
Highlander forgotten her forgot Honda
sure we'll check out this Amanda anyway
Alistair Hart book is fantastic for
anyone who's read man's search for
meaning by Viktor Frankl like imagine
that and make it extreme like this guy
was captured by the Japanese put in
numerous prisoner of war camps helped to
build the bridge over the river kwai was
strapped in a tin basically a tin box
and left out in the Sun for a couple of
days suffered with like every tropical
disease under the Sun basically had
dysentery constantly for four years then
got strapped on one of these death ships
and didn't have any food or water over a
hundred degrees Fahrenheit for like a
week as he traveled across the ocean
then got out then got put in another
death camp and then got hit by the
aftershock of Nagasaki's bomb drop like
literally got blown off his feet by the
heat and then kept quiet about it for 60
years 50 years and then basically wrote
this is a memoir
which is also a movement to call the
Japanese government to count for the
atrocities that occurred under that
because it was kind of brushed under the
rug a little bit had the Gutenberg
trials and things like that way there
wasn't really an equivalent was a
Gutenberg sure I wasn't I'm not sure the
Nazi war crime trials but you didn't
have an equivalent really for the
Japanese so anyway he did all that and
that again the contrast there that you
can apply between that life in your own
and the same occurs for a lot of things
so we've moved through we've had
inversion yeah we've had contrasts the
Charlie Munger speech that you mentioned
about is pretty seminal at kind of
starting this off right the video
Gardein will make the link to the video
up here in the top corner and if you are
watching if you're listening on itunes
it will be in the show notes below but
it's just a way on the contrast one
because we've checked this metaphor
before just like finally hit it home and
this is the perfect example of the power
of contrast that comes from Charlie
Munger speech you know the book its
hands experiment right so I think it
comes from Bob Sheol Dinis work where
they had three buckets so on the left
hand side they had a freezing ice cold
bucket on the right hand side they had a
boiling hot pocket so what they get
people to do is put their left hand in
the freezing one and the right hand in
the boiling one and leave it there for a
minute to write then in the middle
they'd have a lukewarm just neutral
water that they've moved their hands
into and obviously the one that had just
been in the freezing cold water suddenly
felt like this water was incredibly part
whereas the one that had been in the
boiling hot water that water felt
incredibly cold so objectively the water
is the exact same temperature but it's
just what your contrasting against and
that is like the true power of contrast
that I see that's so good so Charlie
Munger's speech was actually delivered
it's like a was a graduation speech down
nurse it was - there's one nothing
university South Carolina I believe and
there's also the one he gave - which is
a graduation speech but there's also the
one that he gave a Stanford University
called the psychology of human
misjudgment when he breaks down sort of
mental model by mental model that people
should look to look to apply to their
lives
there's a shortened version of that
which will be linked in the show notes
below which has actually been animated
sent that to you a little while ago
which is really good and yeah I mean
this appears to be that speech seems to
form the basis of one of our favorite
blogs which is Farnam Street but many
people don't know Farnam Street is the
address of how the wait warrants you
know what it used to be before that know
what it would the predecessor to that it
was the zip code it was just this weird
collection of letters so anyone who is a
big big fan of shame perish from
farnum's reason he did a podcast on Bret
McKay's Art of Manliness podcast mhm and
that is fantastic and tells you an awful
lot about just how Farnam Street came to
be and that's how I found out about the
beginning Charlie Munger's psychology of
human misjudgment was basically what
triggered or as appears to be what
triggered Shane parish to start this
blog FS stop blog which is one of the
best resources on the internet the fact
that it's free blows my mind just for
learning about these mental models he
has a list of a hundred and nine which
will also be linked in the show notes
below and you should definitely check
out you can clip the entire page with
Evernote clipper and send it to your
Kindle so you can read or you can put it
in pocket or whatever you're using to
read but that appears to be kind of the
patient zero for the start of this and
then we're going to move through a few
more for the rest day so I'm thinking so
we can go into one that like people hear
a lot about now mainly it's been
popularized by Elon Musk which is like
first principles which comes from
physics so this is the I like the
basically art form of deconstructing
something so you can in order to
reconstruct it so like a great example
of that is where Yvonne talks about I
believe it's like the batteries for see
the test or a SpaceX and people would
say Anubis baby was particularly SpaceX
and it was like let's say for example it
was twelve hundred pounds of batteries
named ones like reasons from analogy so
they just read them from the way it's
been before and just copy and paste up
thinking like really muddy thinking so
they have a particular mode of looking
at the world yeah which is called
reasoning from analogy yeah what's that
so reason from analogy so this is the
example right so let's say with the
batteries it will an example of reason
from analogy it would be it's always
cost twelve hundred pounds to create
this battery there's no way you could do
it on a
like an affordable way to do it so just
breaking down from first principles
would be to go okay
let's deconstruct what this question
actually is so what is the battery made
up of so like lithium and you go you go
breaks down all the the ingredients that
are part of the batteries and he goes
okay how much would this cost to buy off
the london metal exchange and it comes
down to like a tenth of the price and
goes okay so then all we need to do is
find a cost effective way of putting
these ingredients back together to
create the battery so that's literally
like first principles thinking like
fully breaking it down to its core
components Paul Graham has like an
unbelievable essay called like why not
to start a start-up and he basically
like if you ask that people like Felisa
you'll have makes you want to start
businesses right and there's there's
this like conversation going on in their
head and often it whether it's like
breaking up with someone or starting a
new chapter in the life there's like all
this stuff going on in their head
there's like 12 different reasons all
into one that are all intertwining so
what Paul Gray and basically recommends
doing is how can you even assess a
situation until you've gone through
every single reason written them down
and then look is that valid or watch the
truth about that and break down the
reality of each situation that's
stopping you from doing something but
first principles is a fascinating one
like remember we chat about this before
but like where to actually apply it to a
memory we could try that now which is
that one thing I'm obsessed with is how
can we completely destroy the modern
education system because I despise it
with a passion um so let's just look at
like education from like a first
principles perspective so like a great
example
like instead of talking about what
subjects let's just break it down to
what time should school start because
that's a huge part of it right and the
time they arrive and the time that they
leave and so like Daniel grass who has
like some amazing mental models talks
about this he goes why does school start
at 9:00 a.m. it's so that parents can
drop the kids off before they go to work
right but all the research suggests that
kids starts the remembered right when
you're a teenager you wake up you want
to wake up at 12 yes you have a whole
nation of kids who are under slap
since sleep-deprived no wonder they
[ __ ] hate school well that's why they
changed the start time of high school in
America in a particular state I can't
remember this is sited in Joe Rogan's
Matthew Walker podcast number eleven or
nine and what he says is they moved the
start time for school back by I think an
hour or an hour and a half and they
reduced the number of road traffic
accidents done by 25% in people under
the age of 21 because the sleep
deprivation that was being suffered was
out or that the times that school was
starting was out of alignment with the
natural circadian rhythm of people of
that age and by avoiding that they
downstream from that didn't need to
change anything to do with crossings
didn't need to change anything to do
with education just needed to give the
people behind the wheel a bit more sleep
so going back to yeah I completely agree
so going back to the first principles
perspective right so let's look at what
time should school start then it's
almost how do we teach so one thing I
find fascinating is if I was learning a
subject now I wouldn't learn ten fifteen
subjects at once so why are we doing
this for kids that would it be better to
have a year where they go deep in
biology or they go deep in a specific
subject that they've chosen why is it
you do like an hour of history and then
an hour of psychology than an hour of
this and as a result you chase ten
rabbits and getting on may be a bit of
that is due to low attention like if if
all I had to do was like maths for a
year or even a week probably get pretty
bored I think there's probably a
refreshing sir.you the point that you're
making though is that you can look it as
opposed to accepting the old guard and
reasoning from analogy which is copy and
paste you can actually just start
scratch and look at it so I think we do
this with the relationship series we
look at okay so exactly what is supposed
to be a relationship and why why are we
accepting of certain things what are the
best practices that you can move through
what are the component parts that are
distilled down to its core elements what
are the actual individual parts of what
a relationship should be and how you
should interact with someone so yeah
first principles anyone who's watched
Elon Musk and Joe Rogan will have heard
him talk about this a lot and he's a big
proponent of it right 100% and like I
was thinking about I was away in Gran
Canaria recently and it was like saying
it's one of those holidays like we're
used I'll go to like Amsterdam óbuda
pass with friends and you'll be drinking
and going out and you come away from
that needing a holiday or is this he was
just isolated in the certain just
thinking about stuff and I was trying to
break down like what's the first
principles of my life like what are the
things that really matter and I thinking
all that I sort of one and I want to
optimize his time and energy so timers
in how much like time I have in the day
what am I doing with my time and then
obviously energy as well because let's
say I have 24 hours in a day to do
whatever I want but I'm really sick like
that's a pointless life right so if you
every different decision now I'm just
trying to filter through will this give
me more time will this give me more
energy how do I want to spend my time
how do I want to spend my energy whereas
beforehand you have so many met
analogies just rolling through your head
of how you should be living your life
like should I be doing this because this
person thinks that or should I be here
at 25 should I be doing this like what
should I be should I care about how many
followers I've got here at where's now
I'm getting just thinking about time and
energy and you realize that's all you've
got and that's all you should ultimately
optimize for when you break it down to
its core components what's more
important than time and energy so Cal
Newport talks about work done equals
time times intensity yeah that's the
formula that he comes with as part of
deep work
mm-hm and you are correct I can't help
but think as you're saying that that if
anyone ever needed one sentence
justification for why you should go
sober that you've just you've just
deployed it they're like because it saps
both of the two most precious resources
that you have as first principles in
your life so what we got next what we're
moving on to so what we got next
what's it just just to finish off the
first principles when I use the perfect
like metaphor similar to the buckets one
right yeah is that opens that if you
look when the wheel was invented it was
in many like 2000 I have God knows how
many years ago right but bags have been
around for ages and for ages people were
just reason by knowledge analogy and we
just make a prettier looking bad
and then around about the 70s or 80s one
guy I realized why the [ __ ] can't be
putting wheels on these things
he puts wheels on it and now you could
could you imagine suitcases without
without wheels it's not rory sutherland
ism isn't it on the podcast I did with
Rory he said I can't believe we put a
man on a moon before we put wheels on a
suit yeah it's crazy part of that he
says is likely due to the fact that
inline skates and skateboarding costs
and casters and things like that became
cheaper as a byproduct of the
proliferation of those minor sports but
the fact that you could have like you
could have definitely put at the very
least a little roller or something on
the bottom of it yeah you completely
correct so next one um this one's like
have not recently fleshed out as much
elsewhere but it's one I've been
thinking about agent I'm gonna write
Twitter friend only at some point
because that's what I do I'll have an
idea brewing around in my head for weeks
and okay I've got Fred now I'm so like
double Fink which comes from George
Orwell's 1984 right which to hold 2
contradictory beliefs and you had at the
same time we were chatting about this
like any comments you see these mental
models elsewhere right so NASA Antelope
has like the barbel strategy where it's
all the way to evil ends of the spectrum
so the way I was thinking about this on
the drive down today which is people say
you don't want to think in black and
white I think you want to sorry black or
white thinking you want black and white
thinking it's the shades of grey is
where you go to die so anything like
in-between so we'll give like the
perfect example of this like the ability
to do intense focus deep work with
intense serendipity and socialization
and all that stuff in the middle is
where you go to die like black and white
thinking is so underrated and the
perfect example because I know NYX as Bo
I heard a podcast with him in Navarre
where he calls it like quantum 4 where
he's sort of holding two opinions at the
same time he's running through running
running them through his head like Conor
McGregor's coach John Kavanagh he talks
about how during training he wants his
fighters to be completely egoless and
think they're basically losses and just
constantly obsessed with improving he
wants them to get tapped by everyone and
learn what they're doing wrong but as
soon as fight week comes he wants them
to think they're completely invincible
so it's
weird like paradox that exists of like
two polar end of the spectrums that you
have to exist between and Matthew Siyad
has a similar concept with like golfers
so let's say for example a golfers about
to take a swing before he takes that
swing he has to have extreme self-doubt
where he's going okay what clubs should
have been using here what's the perfect
swing but as soon as he's gone through
all that self-doubt and gone through of
it all he then needs to switch to a
state of complete and total confidence
so it's that doublethink
two ends of the spectrum that you have
to exist between whereas if you sort of
a midway between it where you a little
bit confident but a little bit
self-doubt those shades of Gray's just
where you go to die I totally get that
man Matthew sired if you are listening
please reply to me I would love I'd love
to have you on the podcast but you're
paying me harder than some girls do so
you know that's pretty hard yeah I do I
do get that I like the idea of black and
white thinking I think what a lot of
people will tend to do is allow
cognitive biases to come in and they
will do white and white thinking or
black and black yeah of course which is
another we were discussing last night
over dinner about how steel mining
another person's argument can be a
fantastic way to get around this so
Charlie Munger has he calls it his iron
prescription in that he refuses to have
or state publicly an opinion on
something
unless he can state the opposing opinion
better than the other side can select
the best like one of the best political
experiments I've ever seen was on which
analyzed last night was John the Jimmy
Kimmel show so what he did during the
Trump and Hillary election would he
basically would go out in the street and
interview a load of like Hillary
supporters and I think they did the same
for Trump supporters as well but they
would list like a load of policies that
Hillary Clinton was planning on
implementing and they'd be gone yet I
said that's a great idea that's
absolutely great immigration policies
great economic policies but at the end
you'd basically reveal to them that it
was Trump's policies and you'd see like
the cognitive dissonance where the MPC
computers were just about to like
explode right and that's that goes back
to another mental model which is like
identity and Charlie talks about this
about when you go around shouting
publicly as you do with these
students now like I believe X I believe
why I believes that you you think you're
drilling it to the outside world but
you're actually drilling it into
yourself and as soon as you identity had
identify as something that's it it can
even be a superpower or like the death
of you like if you would for example
identifies like a nonsmoker with James
clear talks about it's a way of kicking
smoking right but if you like I know
Robert chill Dini
he got to the stage where he wouldn't
want to sign a petition but something
that he believed in because he then
begin to identify with that cause and
would find it very difficult to think
clearly identities are really really
weird what is a difficult one can we do
signal versus noise go for it
so signal versus noise like this is one
of my favorite yeah like how you go
about particularly in the 21st century
like establishing what's true and what's
gonna be gone tomorrow and you can
almost tie in another mental model there
which is like The Linde effect so The
Linde effect I believe it was a load of
comedians sat around in a cafe and they
realized that a comedians lifespan was
almost there how let's say for example
they've been around for two years you
can assume they're gonna be around for
two years minimum future lifespan
exactly so if let's say a books been
around like the Origin of Species by
Charles Darwin it's been around for a
couple hundred years you can assume it's
gonna be around for a couple hundred
years more at least what's the [ __ ]
blog post you've just read on BuzzFeed
if it's been around for a day it's
probably not going to be around there
tomorrow yeah so I mean you'll hear if
you look on Twitter and you see the
circles that George moves within by the
way George is followed by some of the
biggest dicks on Twitter and by big
dicks I mean like honking huge throbbing
really impressive people Navarra Becan
rory sutherland doesn't just recently
don't you as well hasn't he there's like
there's it does it know there's a number
of others but he has done you and the
the circles that these guys move with
him you'll see them talk a lot about
read a Lindy book yeah and what they
mean by that is read something which has
been around for a significant period of
time so it's envious that and the head
David Parral has a great point has a
great podcast in or start one I think
who's trying to keep for a boy maybe
about this
and if 99% of people all the content
they consume was made in the last 24
hours
yeah and he sought and then that ties
into another meant and what you see how
these are all links right which is like
evolution which by the fact it's only
been around for a day you can assume
it's half span it's the life spans
owning me another day more like that is
awful content whereas if something
survived for 200 years you know there's
something like foundational to that
material that you should look to seek
out so you can see how these all tie
together that's why the classic books
are the classics right yeah that's why
war and peace or 1984 is a good read she
won the best [ __ ] example some ones
but I I'm a I made this mistake and like
I know for a fact the loads of other
people with like particularly that
entrepreneurship and business so the
amount of people and I love Gary Vee I
like ty Lopez I think they're probably
doing a lot of good for the world Grant
Cardone all these like modern YouTube
entrepreneurs which they aren't even the
richest dudes by people in the world
they probably got about a seven eight
figured net worth but let's leave that
aside um like I said I'm not criticizing
these guys but the amount of people I
know who is similar to me who only
listen to their content but have no clue
who John rockefeller is yeah who have no
clue who Benjamin Franklin is no clue
who JP Morgan is like the actual people
throughout history who've change society
like John rockefeller was the the first
billionaire his net worth at one point I
believe is like 3% of the USG GDP so he
shits all on Jeff Bezos like ships on a
Taser so if you actually go back through
history and see what survived you're
gonna get like so many gems from
studying like rock of it like I'll get
to do some example say I was watch so I
listened to that I was going that so
applies to me aside like [ __ ] I need to
watch some documentary somebody does
seduce people get seduced by newer is
better yeah which is just a bias as he
buy into the beginning the momentum is
recency by recency bias yeah and on top
of recency bias there'll be what's the
one like closeness bias like where it's
just the fact that it's more visible or
vice that it's the brand-new self-help
book which just came out one month ago
you like that look that's got all the
latest research in it's got this I mean
like well yeah but looking live look at
Lindy like that it's not a Lindy book
like it's been around for a month so
presume
probably gonna be around for a month
maybe more yeah you don't know that's
why when you hear rory sutherland he
cites bob calvini all the time like that
art of persuasion is like hmm yes it was
crazy about Bob Joe just off topics
briefly so his book persuasion I believe
it's true that Charlie and Warren love
that book so much I think it probably
made a sold millions of copies so he's
probably done well from that but Charlie
and Warren loved that book so much I
believe they gave him Series A shares in
Berkshire Hathaway I don't know that
mean um so as in like Berkshire have
away their business and they gave him
like high-end shares with in Berkshire
Hathaway because they loved the book so
much does it contribute yeah [ __ ]
panting Bob Shalini was behind because
they knew tines like Scott Adams and go
for a mentor couple minimalist remember
and if Scott's a big like fan of his but
he was behind a lot of Obama's
presidency like a campaigns which goes
to show you like that's one of the best
campaigns
that's my ever-existing apparently when
Clinton was beginning to turn it round
because he looked like Trump and
Clinton's persuasion techniques
Trump just completely shot all over
Hillary right but when Hillary hired
chill Deanie and brought him in it hers
began to improve
I consider whoo considerably but whilst
on the topic of Scott Adams he has some
great mental models which Scott Scott
Adams is the creator of Dilbert like the
one the most controversial / interesting
Twitter feeds if you ever want to learn
how to write so you can learn within two
minutes the essay is called like the
best sorry what's it called it's called
the day you became a better writer and
within it's about ten sentences and he
covers everything you can know that like
learning how to write like you
completely changed the way I write first
and it's just pure pure simplicity but
he has like like goals versus systems as
a way of like navigating the career
space right or what you want to do with
your life so a goal for example would be
this you obviously you're insane when it
comes to the health stuff so a goal
would be like I want to bench 200 kg a
day or I want to get to 10 percent body
fat and I mean first off you know it but
the only one right 90% of people never
even reach their goals
whereas a system and similar to jail
under James clearer covers this a little
bit with atomic habits a system is
something that you do every single day
and let's say you look at those two
realities like two
identical versions of George one that
does goals one of the systems so the
systems is actually what the work
requires to get the goal so you're more
likely to get there but also through
doing systems thinking because you're
like hitting it every day you're happy
every day and like as you mentioned you
can tell the car analogy that you told
me yesterday rather than a goal you're
literally miserable until you hit it and
then when you hit it the day next day
you're like okay what's the next thing
so systems swing it but tell D what was
the current are you talking last night
so there's a couple a couple of things
James clear what one of the main reasons
that he doesn't like goals as a route
towards direction in life is that you
presume the reason if there's two people
that have the same goals and one person
wins and another person loses the
presumption is because one person's goal
was greater than the others or that
someone wanted it more but when you put
the Olympic final of the hundred meters
there's no one on the start line who
doesn't have the goal of winning the
difference between all of them is the
system yeah it's not the goal and the
car analogy that James clear uses which
is fantastic is that if you are on the
right trajectory but haven't completed
the goal that you want to and
complaining about it it is exactly the
same as sitting in a car moving on a
motorway and complaining about not being
there yet
you're like hang on you're moving in the
right direction at the optimal speed and
doing all of the things you need to do
all that's left is to continue mm-hmm
like it sounds when you look at that and
when you analogize that it sounds so
juvenile to go there yeah like an you
know the throw you throw the toys out of
the pram and yet on a daily basis we all
see people going well like I've been
dying for four weeks and I've been
hitting the gym everyday and look I'm
still not 5% body fat I mean like it you
just need to continue to sit on the
motorway yeah with your foot press down
on the accelerator pedal so let's go
back to signal versus noise so signal
versus noise I'm remind me to come on to
a lot of poser effect cuz that's the
ultimate mental model but signal versus
noise is then sorry we would chat about
this last night when we mean Chris often
have this thing where we have strands of
conversations that just end up like
absolutely I bring you back to the main
purpose is good at this stuff so signal
versus noise is detecting like the
information that actually matters versus
99% of the noise that's out there that
is just absolutely garbage that people
can often get confused with the bluff
the perfect analogy for this for
understanding signal versus noise is
that trading one that I mentioned to you
last night so let's say that you were
looking at the daily report from the
market you'd put a trade on on in some
stock in the plan was to leave it long
term if you were to look and this is a
shame Parrish ISM if you were to look at
it at the beginning of year one and at
the end of year one you've probably got
50% of the information of 50% of the
movement is going to be signal and 50%
of the movement is going to be noise so
you think oh okay like you know 50% of
what has happened I probably need to
take heed of however as you begin to
increase the frequency at which you look
at the market movement let's say that
you now look at it every six months
there's more noise and less signal let's
say that you look at it every day
there's almost all noise and almost zero
signal because all that you're concerned
about is does this information help me
to make an effective two
and signal versus noise explains or
helps you to understand that you have to
be able to discern what is important and
what you should take heed of versus what
is going to be tomorrow's fish-and-chips
rapper yeah and Lindy ties into that
quite nice this is it right all these
mental models kind of like a latticework
right they all fit together but the the
godfather for me the ultimate meta
mental model I don't you know if you
know the lot of poser effect this comes
from Charlie Wright which is there like
it's okay another mentor it's got too
many minimalist it then you have like
compound interest when things all
motivate and obviously it builds
momentum on itself
so when you have multiple mental models
working together or multiple multiple
cognitive biases working together that's
when you have like a holy [ __ ] effect so
like I'll give you a good example of
this is you know auctions so let's say
when people go to auctions you have a
few like Warren and Charlie now refuse
to go to auctions because they've got
screwed out of them so many times so
let's say for example and items on sale
you've got to look at what like
cognitive biases you have there so first
off you have like social proof because
you've got everybody looking at you and
you're trying to impress them you've got
contrast because it's like the frog in
boiling water so that's a you said
twenty pounds to begin with but now
you're at two grand but because every
time you're just going up a little bit
more a little bit more a little bit more
so you don't feel it you've also got
consistency bias because you've said I
want this and you've said it to a
roomful of people
you've got Authority bias because you've
got the guy on the stage probably got
sunk cost fallacy
you've got sunk costs so when you have a
that's a lot of poser effect is when you
have like five or six of these things
working together and just compounding
and that's when you create like
something like real crazy so mental
models are almost you never see them by
themselves they're all like connected
and intricated and within themselves
it's fascinating is it direction of a
speed or is it a speed of a velocity
that's a shame parish one which is which
is i think what he talks about the
difference between efficiency and
effectiveness and Johnny talks about
this a lot that he thinks a lot of
people and if the reason that he doesn't
use Alfred the reason he doesn't use
Alfred is because he thinks he is making
himself faster at going in and in
optimal
erection okay a suboptimal direction as
opposed to he wants to spend all of his
time just making sure that whatever
direction he is moving in is as
effective as possible and he's like
adding speed on top of a poor direction
he's just sending you further in a in
the wrong way
mm-hmm and that does make a lot of sense
and that obviously ties in with the sunk
cost fallacy which is I have dedicated X
amount of my life to whatever this
particular direction is so far I may as
well continue going and you're like nah
man like cut your losses like if you
know in your heart of hearts that under
the decision would make you more happy
in another direction we're making more
happy bounced off and go that way so I
also begot give me some give me some
more man this is one that I sort of
sorry I didn't create I got it from Eric
Weinstein but I wrote an essay on it
which is that high agency and I think
this is that the most important
personality trait when I look at like
friends who I know we're gonna do [ __ ]
and friends who I'd know probably aren't
gonna do [ __ ] it hi agency is by far
like the single biggest factor so the
way I require Stein talks about it is
like do you believe the story that's
gaming to you like so let's say for
example I go Chris you can't set up an
events company or you're 20 years old
okay Lowe agency people go alright okay
I'll just go and get a job expose out
here whereas the high agency person it's
like [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'm going to like
figure out a way of doing this and I
there's some almost like core tenets of
high agency when I see people and I want
to get much better at this I'm not an
expert here but it's almost the ability
to have like a real high locus of
control so like Josh Waitzkin has this
metaphor where what he's doing to teach
his son right now almost like a locus of
control is whenever the weather's [ __ ]
but he goes out and plays in there and
goes look how great the weather is where
is the average person whenever it's an
awful weather day so
oh it's rubbish today so never outsource
your locus of control
you control your mental state the second
one is like going back to first
principles earlier so you almost have to
read them from first principles and go
okay everyone's doing this is that
actually the correct way let's break it
down the next one you was thinking you'd
like some like insane work ethics and
you're gonna need some like creativity
and if you're figuring out like how this
is how you identify agency people that
come from Jeff Bezos and he calls it
resourcefulness but basically exact same
thing which is if you was in a
third-world prison what friends
would you call to break you out and that
you can immediately you'll pick now to
take ten seconds you got which friends
with that call and then you've got okay
that's a high agency person because you
by their very nature you can have to be
quite smart to do that you got some
reason from first principles you can
have to use all the stuff that you have
to have internal locus of control right
hi agent I'll give you some examples
right so I need to do a thread on this I
might one of my favorite examples of
higher agency behavior and I hope you
make a film on this was you know the
whole Silk Road stuff right so Silk Road
the arguably the biggest drug empire
certainly ever online one the biggest
drug empires ever do you know who took
him took Dread Pirate Roberts down the
guy who's running all sober man the FBI
was after him couldn't do [ __ ] DEA was
after him could a new [ __ ] the person
who took raw raw soul breakdown was a
IRS tax inspector via google for me that
is mental and then we can go into like a
symmetry right so the fact that one
individual on their [ __ ] computer of
an internet connection can outperform
the FBI and the DEA also do you know how
he found him so he just decided he
started googling went back through to
the old forums and found a post on a
Bitcoin forum about it
contacted the forum about the email
address that was registered and it was
Ross orbit at gmail.com and this is how
it gets mentor so he then presents it to
his superiors who didn't believe him for
mumps and then they big as they as they
finally began to catch up with him the
the actually realized he was correct
yeah all along and this is like the
power of high agency behavior like you
have Mark Zuckerberg in his college dorm
room who can take down the entire media
industry you have Jeff Bezos who's
taking down all of commerce basically
you have Satoshi nakamoto's you could
have is definitely designing the banking
sector exactly you've got Joe Rogan
who's completely taking over median bro
cutie pie gets more views like four
times as many views of CNN right so like
high agency behavior is the most like
important personality trait out there
like another question that Peter Thiel
has each is ask people like what's your
tenure goal and they'll go okay so I
want to build X so I said he goes how
would you that in six months and then
[ __ ] you start like going [ __ ] okay I've
got to figure out how to do this now
like high agency behavior is probably
the most important things cause fit and
this explains why you have people who've
read all these [ __ ] box and they
don't do anything because
by its very word you have like oh no you
chat about your business part of Darren
right who's not that book smart bar bet
you could say his high agency if he was
in a field world prison I bet you'd be
one the people you will t be out
immediately he'd have done their
accounts for them and they've let him
free no you aren't you are completely
but do another example watch one on
YouTube do with that so this kid from a
rough part of London black kid from
London and he wants to be a success
right so most people would like research
it online or do X Y Zed you know what he
did and the good thing about her agency
behaviour because by its very nature
because it's so low barrier if you go
above and beyond everyone else you
should stand out like a [ __ ] sore
thumb so you know he did he found out he
just searched where is the richest part
of London realized it was Kensington and
he started knocking on doors asking for
advice this the second house that he
knocked on I believe it was the MD of
Blackrock
who just said you're an internship yeah
and then you got internship there and
like that for me is like wow that's some
like real high agency stuff yeah I know
that I want to talk about asymmetries I
know the asymmetry I don't know if it
classes particularly as a mental model
but it's some yeah you said I think you
want to be as loose as possible these
mental models and however it works for
you so this almost comes from yeah of
course is it comes from mathematics
right where it's it's a very
asymmetrical relationship but like the
inverse of symmetry right so a good way
of looking at it is upside and downside
risk right so asymmetrical risks are
something where the upside is incredibly
small and the downside is is hormoz
bottom almost bottomless perfect example
texting while striving yep drink drink
driving like this there's so many out
there unprotected sex unprotected sex
yeah because let's say let's go back to
the texting while driving one the
benefit that you get is probably
responding a lull to a group chat which
you not even remember that message you
not negligible from now the the risk
that you have is make being paralyzed
for the rest of your life and then up in
prison killing someone mm-hm so that's
like asymmetrical risk but there's a
flip side of that right which is like
asymmetric opportunities and it's like
this all the time so you flip it on its
head and my one of my favorite ones for
like asymmetrical opportunities is just
DMing people anyone who you think's
doing like something interesting just
how you love this and its particular if
you have a skill you can offer just go
you know you could do exercise that
and I guess that's how me and you is
sitting here right now so I met you
right and then the that took me so the
downside there was 30 seconds of my time
let's say nothing happened I've lost 30
seconds yeah if it goes well you've met
like a new good friend right yeah so the
asymmetry you could hear you can see
everywhere mm-hmm a symmetrical
opportunities and asymmetrical risks are
something that I try and map a lot of my
life onto as it is at the moment perfect
example of that is someone tagged me in
a tweet from Daniel sloth saying that he
was coming to New Castle to do a live
show I replied and said hi Daniel before
you go and do your live show do you want
to come on a podcast you've got large
with a beautiful northern accent and
five million
listen minutes over the last year are
you up for it he replied and said yeah
yeah downstream from that me and Daniel
speak on what's up probably once a week
now I've got a good mate I probably got
somewhere to stay when I want to go
Edinborough and we hit 50k views in like
a couple of weeks on that me like that
was asymmetric oh yeah well it's it's
it's crazy next one I want to go on to
second and third-order thinking or like
oh just first or a second third order
thinking so the way this is like a very
simple one but it's on those things
until you break it down to the first
principles you never really understand
it which is the first order effects of
your actions so I thought the best
analogy I have is the two duality of
taking the stairs or taking the elevator
so first all the consequences of both so
if you take the stairs
first all the consequence a bit [ __ ]
like you feel yep but Matt get bit the
stitch you're out of breath right
whereas you take the elevator the first
order consequence is great you just
there I just stood there you'd have to
do anything but then you look at the
second order consequences so the second
order consequences are taking the stairs
is that you get like some cardiovascular
exercise and particularly if you do this
over the like 10 years I know Jeff Bezos
apparently never takes a lift it always
takes the stairs so once you do that
over 10 years you get the cardiovascular
benefits then the second-order
consequences have been in the lift is
that you're getting no cardiovascular
benefits and then the third-order
consequences when you go even further
than that like further in the future
which is that you're actually wiring
your brain
all right so whenever you go okay I'm
presented with a difficult option or an
easy option which one do I take
if you take the stairs up
time you're wiring your bed I always
take the difficult option whereas if you
take the elevator all the time
the third order consequences are and
your wiring your brains let's hit the
easy option so you almost have first
order second order third order and often
what's what gives you the most returning
the first order [ __ ] you in the second
and third order but what gives you what
screws you in the first order actually
provides so much more benefit in the
second or third order but James clear
talks about this a lot in atomic habits
where he says that the reason that
people continually do bad habit is
because the felt cost at the time is
almost not there and the reason that
people don't do good habits is that the
felt discomfort is actually quite
palpable but that the goals are hidden
downstream from that and that you need
to look at am i doing something that
future me would be happy about is me
tomorrow going to be happy about what me
now is doing and that's probably a
pretty good way to look at it I think a
good way to look at second the second
order thinking is predict in however
long it's going to take for this
decision to kick in whether or not you
would think that that will be a good
decision because the you right now and
the you tomorrow two very different
people when there's a crucial decision
in front of you or even a small decision
in front of you a good way to for anyone
who's trying to stick to a diet like if
you've got a chocolate bar in your hand
you right now wants to eat the chocolate
bar you tomorrow might think [ __ ] wish
I hadn't eaten that chocolate bar like
you tomorrow will exist for a lot longer
than you right now will yeah because you
right now is transient and you tomorrow
is forever
well Kahneman has that bit where it's
like um where it's much easier to spot
those mistakes in other people than it
is to see them in yourself well that's
why I think the jordan peterson ism of
be friends with people who want the best
for you and treat yourself like somebody
you are responsible for helping like if
you have those two things be friends
with people who want the best for you
and treat yourself like you're someone
you are responsible for helping if you
can map that over the top of personal
and social for yourself and we
went back to the very very first metal
model that you brought up which was just
not even aiming for wins simply avoiding
losses yeah like you have pari toad yeah
that's another you have managed to get
the vast majority of the benefit on a
person already though I won this event
um one I've sort of created it's more of
an activity than a mental model but okay
again it all ties together right which I
call the um the Buffett Franklin's sweep
the stack like I do have to work on the
naming a bit yeah but I'll explain it
does think that that one's gonna catch
on basically wait till you hear it right
so Warren Buffett has like this great
exercise so you know how people talk
about values right like what are your
values like what do you believe in it's
very woolly thinking again going back to
the happiness one right so the way to
looking at it from like an immense
perspective where you can see stuff much
clearer in other people than you can
yourself so Buffett gave a speech
I forgot what university it's at when he
told them to look around the classroom
that you're friends and this is a great
exercise to do and think who would you
say you had a budget to invest who would
you invest ten percent in over your
friends like which friends and which
friends would you short and the great
thing about this you can obviously do it
for financial well-being but you could
almost look at it let's say imagine that
happiness was a currency and go who
would you think who would you invest 10%
in who would you short 10% so once
you've got list of those names you got
okay why would I invest in him or why
would I invest in her oh it's because
whenever whenever in a social
interaction they always got the extra
mark for the other person or they're
incredibly honest or they're incredibly
hard-working and you look at the people
who are short and you go oh that
person's like really narcissistic they
always make it about themselves so then
you know okay those are Buffett says
those are the values I need so I'm going
to start looking at how I can implement
them myself
and then those are the values I go to
avoid and make sure I never have them in
myself and this is how that's buff it
and then Franklin kicks in this Benjamin
Franklin used to have a list of thirteen
virtues that every day when he would get
home would go through them and say did I
do that so I've got it now like I've got
a Google sheet of course so it's like so
let's say high agency earlier that's one
the ones in there so I'll go Monday at
the end of the day I go dirty or
anything actually hi agency today
now I didn't okay so well and I think
where could have done that okay and I'll
write that in the street okay I could've
done that
and there's resort then you like you've
actually made values something which you
can understand and apply which I think's
like incredibly difficult for you
yeah the instantiation daily of the
processes or the systems and the
feedback mechanism to ensure that you're
continuing to do those which if you
continue to do them allow you to keep on
the trajectory towards the goals that
are meaningful to you is I think it's so
important and the option to use mental
models is the steps it's the individual
steps that you can take or it's the
stepping stones that you can use on the
river that you're moving over it's not
about getting to the other side it's
just about continuing to step on the
correct stones and once you do that
without putting your foot in the water
you're like okay well like if I continue
to do this at a high enough pace I mean
like the other side is coming like it's
just it's just a case of again there
what else we got so this is again like
this is more like what mental models can
we take from this discipline that we can
apply elsewhere so this was one I'm
fascinated women I'll open up to you
because I've got a few thoughts about it
right so you have the music industry you
have the movie industry and you have the
gaming industry
I assumed I wouldn't sure which one
would rank highest but I assumed it was
relatively the same value the gaming
industry is worth more than the music
and movie like entertainment industry
combined which is crazy right so I'm
immediately thinking there the gaming
industry have a greater understanding of
human psychology better than anybody on
the planet so what mental models can you
take from the way they're designing
video games to apply to real life and
I'm thinking I know some people who are
unbelievable at video games like world
champion level or like elite level and
absolutely messes at their own life and
if you go down like don't bore people
but you're gonna like the whole
simulation hypothesis like this is a
simulation
we're basically playing a big video game
right like you just immediately some
character with some traits and some
stuff and you've got some goals to enter
it's basically a video game so why are
people succeeding at this video game but
then when it comes to real life of being
like awful at it like what's the gap
that what so what the video games have
that that most people's lives are
missing in your opinion
sense of escapism sense of belonging
sense of community obvious feedback
mechanism that shows progression so what
would I agree of laser points that one
thing that I thought was really like
obvious is parameters which you if you
ever do like basic program and you need
parameters to define a function right so
you need like let's say right now might
the parameters of my life or the
everyday person it could be so wide like
and in chat face button each
instagramming research five ten
different careers I need I need to reach
out to these people there's so much
stuff going on that no wonder anxiety in
Google Trends if teen can put that up
there right anxiety will trends is at
its highest I've ever because it's just
unlimited parameters and people just are
adopts have choices people just melt in
it right there isn't a video let's say I
mean you a playing Fifa or Madden or
whatever the kids play right I'm off the
video games there's a clear parameter
I'm trying to get the ball in your net
you're trying to get the ball in my net
whoever gets the ball in the net the
most wins so that's the parameter
whereas most people wake up with like
100 different things you have to do that
day so having Warner to clear things
which are falsifiable against I think is
one thing that video games have the next
thing that they have is levels so an
issue that I've seen this with friends
who like start businesses or have goals
right is that the launch something and
the goal was to make 100 pound online in
a day and they don't make anything and
as a result they immediately quit and
Daniel gross that has a unbelievable
metaphor for this which is let's say for
example right now I'm at level zero and
if you want to learn anything like if
you do this framework it's the most
powerful learning technique I've found
so it's a level ten is making 100 pounds
online every single day I'm at level
zero right now so what a lot of people
do let's say they learn how to do like
look-alike ads they learn how to set up
an online store they learn how to
research an issues they get to level
four right you've got not hit level 10
equip but whereas in video games you
know this little levels each way so
you're constantly stepping up the
progress right and that's why CrossFit
like Daniel gross talks about this
CrossFit is an unbelievable video game
because it has so many of those core
components in their way you're always
progressing each day another thing that
video games have is you know what the
biggest one is I think it's identity so
when something goes wrong in my day
likes because I identify as me
it can ruin my whole day whereas this a
video game you look at the character as
a third person so if you can almost do
that with your own life you can see from
crystal clear the same way when you see
friends who were going through
relationship issues or they're they're
in a job that they hate and they're not
quitting it you can see it so clearly in
somebody else because you're completely
detached from them it's like buddy isn't
right you detachment ski in a video game
you have that you don't if the character
fails yeah of course you're a bit pissed
off but you're not they're three years
later talking to a psychologist go in a
car believe I failed you an immediate
yourself as if you're someone you're
responsible for helping sadly but look
at look at it from an ID like but look
at other people that what mistakes are
they making and then go okay how am I
making those mistakes I identities a
huge factor as well as the sense of
community so what whoever takes these
psychology models from video games and
applies them to real real life is gonna
he's gonna win big awesome man what have
we got left can we do a quick fire round
what have you got we can do so I have a
really really basic one which is input
versus output this comes from like
computer science I got this from an
episode of Tim Ferriss where this guy
called Sammi I can't focus last name is
that when there was leading cyber
security experts and he if you search
myspace Sammi like he hacked into my
space back in the day basically added
himself to everyone yeah I remember this
he run a thing which he added himself to
ten and then that person added ten of
their friends to him and then ten and
then tell you exponentially and he got
like all all of my space within la
tienda so but it was interesting like
Tim Ferriss asking like what you learn
for programming or like that you've
applied to your own life so that mentor
model from programming or computer
science which is inputs and outputs if
you want different is that whole Albert
Einstein quite right if you want
different outputs you have to have
different inputs like Sam Altman who's
part of YC has this like great quote
which is like extreme people get extreme
results and then normal people get
normal results I'm fascinated by how
many people want to be cool or be normal
yet want completely different results to
everyone else yeah so embracing being
weird as a way of life I think is like
one of the most powerful things that you
can do because if you're not weird by
the
definition you're progressing to the
mean you are like average man I'm
singing from the same hymn sheet as
yourself why we are fated to be lonely
by the school of life Alain de Botton on
there which is my most cited video by
miles considering it's four minutes long
in that he says that loneliness is a
kind of tax that we have to pay to atone
for a certain complexity of mind if
you're a person who has contrarian
thoughts or is different to the mean
different to the normal distribution if
you're out on the tales it's natural for
your thoughts to be too subtle contrary
or alarming to be acceptable by society
at large and given the choice between
honesty and acceptability most of us
choose the latter but to be uncommon
amongst uncommon men and to achieve
things that other people haven't you
need to presume that you have to do
things that other people are not so this
is it right so one of my favourite
people for this is Youssef right because
he's just he's the niche guy amongst
niche guys there's the uncommon amongst
uncommon men metaphor would get and if
if you said okay Levin could Dean put
the video of him doing the snatch
snatches in public yeah so we so that
video right there I think could say so
much about the way to behave and I've
started about embracing this so my
favorite quote is that people think
we've never even gotten to this mentor
model the map versus terrain right so
people think they do that people think
they're going to rise to the occasion
whereas they actually sink to their
level of training so this is a mental
model that comes from like Navy SEALs
and Royal Marines in that they drill
everything into your [ __ ]
consciousness so you never make a
mistake whereas most people think I'll
read a book on by Peter Thiel called
zero to one I'm going to be a
billionaire no it's about what you drill
every single day the same reason that
Neil deGrasse Tyson doesn't have a cover
on his phone exactly right so if you
want to be if you want to stand out from
the crowd you can't wait till that
moment comes along when Warren Buffett
calls you up and goes yes I want to
invest X what I said no you have to
practice being [ __ ] weird every
single day
so the youssef one there what's great
about it is that he's drilling people
looking at him like he
weirdo for a positive action that's the
key right so I'll do this with service
stations now I'll just do yoga in public
and I start you start you get that
monkey mind going off people looking at
you people think you're weird but
there's people there who are eatin like
McDonald's
there's another person smoking there
right and nobody's judging them and
that's an action that's negative for
them just more acceptable but I'm doing
one that's for you exactly so you have
to condition yourself to be able to deal
with that and drill it into your
conscious hi agency again hi agency
right so then this is we'll go back to
the first principles redesigning
education the first class and I would
this is one thing I do with my kids
every single month we do the Asch
conformity Tet you know the Asch
conformity test so they have like a rule
they have like loads of lines
it's like Darren brown 101 and they'll
go how lines are longest and it's
clearly that so nine of the other people
in the room are actors but the
individual doesn't know that they're at
says and they will say that the line
that's this long is is longer than the
one that's that long so they all point
to the right one even though it's
clearly shorter and some people a lot of
people will go yeah I agree with
everybody else in the room yeah so we
have to drill kids to be ash negative
like moral it into their consciousness
one of the problems with doing that
though is that you need a work force
which is compliant yeah you need to have
people that will follow the rules
it doesn't do for my degree but well
okay so this might not be the most
effective way to be but it's the easiest
way for the current iteration of
capitalism to continue but if we like
drill create enough Satoshi nakamoto's
enough software engineers who people
fought for themselves like we'd all be
able to Mason a couple years time right
yeah yeah okay that yes you would also
then have a bunch of people who are you
would have a lot more revolutions which
i think would be quite chaotic and
potentially quite quite dangerous one of
the things before we finish I want to
finish on map versus variance I'll tell
you LaVon it's a lovely once it's my
favorite one one of the things that you
touched on at the very beginning was
about avoiding mistakes and Jordan peaks
and talks about this an awful lot what
he says is that there's an experiment
where rats are in a tube and they starve
the rats at the end of the tube
they waft in the smell of cheese the
rats is tails are attached to a spring
in the spring gives the force back
records the force back to a computer the
rats are running to try and get this
cheese and the starving haven't been fed
for a very long time you'd think that
this right is running as hard as it can
towards something that it wants record
the amount force reset another iteration
they put the smell of cheese at the end
of the tube and then they waft the smell
of a cat in from behind and the rats
pull harder and what that shows is not
only do you need to run towards
something that you want but you need to
run away from something that you fear
and that's why Jordan Peterson's
understand myself calm and self
authoring in the self authoring suite
one of the things that you asks people
to do is to say where would you be in
six months one year three years five
years if you continue to do all of the
worst habits that you have now where
would you be if you did all of the best
habits that you have and the difference
between that contrast the difference
between those two situations is so stark
you're like not only am i running
towards something that I want I'm
running away from something I feel I
look yeah that exercise is really
powerful
um the map versus terrain point which is
if you break it down to its first
principles right so maps are by their
very nature an artificial version of
reality whereas terrain is the actual
version of reality and where possible
you want to seek out terrains and avoid
Maps and this is probably if I'd to look
back online advice I'll give it to my 20
year old self and probably I'll give to
myself right now in five years time
that's the biggest one like instaii use
this metaphor right what would you
rather have live in a world where
everybody's passed their theory driving
tests and that's all they've done or
everybody's failed their practical test
I would take failed their practical test
every single time and we live in a world
where you think because you read a book
about a subjects that you know it so the
closer you can get to reality the better
so this is my issue with gratitude
journals which I think are nice but
let's say on on a true feeling
perspective it's a 2 out of 10 because
you're sat there in your warm bedroom
and you're picturing like for example
that you've not got XYZ but if for
example you walked around the hospital
ward and like looked at people who were
dying in the eyes
that is terrain like you're really
[ __ ] seeing it and until you drill
something into your consciousness you
can't like truly feel it until you've
been in that environment I could see how
like to write like what's better having
an MBA or actually running a startup
they always go to the terrain I think
people seek out maps because it's easy
and you can avoid do and I did this more
than anyone right so you can avoid doing
the hard work but um I remember Yousef
told me that you had said to him hey man
I've got this new project that I'm
considering working on but I'm not going
to talk to you about it until I've done
a lot of work on it because I know that
I will my brain will receive a kick of
dopamine in a sense of satisfaction from
me talking about it as much as me doing
the work and I'm not prepared to give
myself that reward because that is me
playing with the map as opposed to
seeing the terrain and you're totally
right the map by its very definition is
a lower fidelity lower resolution
simulacrum of what is actually occurring
and this is one of the reasons why
people become plan addicts so why they
love like New Year's resolutions are
such a huge thing but when people don't
put them into practice again we go back
to systems versus goals like the system
is the daily instantiation of the
actions you need to take to achieve the
goals that you have determined are
meaningful to you by the values that you
have already conceived so I think it
gives a perfect note to end on which is
two of them which is the green lumber
fallacy because it's related direct to
map and terrain and plank knowledge so
the green lumber fallacy it relates to a
trader who was trading in green lumber
and this guy knew everything about
[ __ ] green lumber light knew it
better than anybody else
but was losing money every single day
there was one guy who didn't understand
why green lumber was green I think he
believed it was painted green or
something like that and he was winning
so he didn't even understand the product
but he understood the terrain and you
see it in the social media world whether
some people who know the like read
articles on these platforms but I know
someone who doesn't know who Sheryl
Sandberg is they're the CEO of Facebook
gates but can build you a Facebook page
better than every single person and this
comes down to plan have you heard a
plank knowledge is my favorite one right
so it comes from Charlie Munger speech
so there's this fear of theoretical
physicist max planck around about the
1930 so there's obviously not many
images out there so nobody knows what he
looks like but they've heard of him and
he would go around giving these speeches
across Europe and he would obviously go
deep into theoretical physics he had a
chauffeur with him so the chauffeur like
had done like a hundred of these and
would sit and watch the lecture and the
chauffeur said can I do this lecture and
so basically he just recited it
word-for-word and and that the I
absolutely smashed it and at the end
somebody asked the chauffeur who the
fort was planned excuse me mister plant
could I ask a question about ABC and he
goes that's such a silly question I'll
let my chauffeur answer it and I don't
know what they never know ever that's a
true tailor warning but that's this so
monger cause this the difference between
chauffeur knowledge and plant knowledge
and the 99% of people out there who like
you see in a social media space I'll
show you see in every single space where
they can recite all the good stuff but
what's your P&L what you actually
produced here like do you actually know
when you question go why why why when
you apply the Fineman technique can you
really answer those questions that's
that is a new one for me but it's
something that I was talking about with
the guy who actually gave me this lovely
jumper that I'm wearing which has saved
me from my sweat patches from earlier on
hot under these lights I was talking to
Ricky yesterday about people who were 25
years old giving life coaching 24 until
about mental models but no but you
understand says you're not doing it from
you're not saying I have had these life
experiences you should listen to me what
you're saying is I understand the the
latticework of understanding or should
lay this across and one of the things
that he was talking about was these
people just have zero skin in the game
so you know what nothing types is about
life coaches he says the only the only
thing you can learn from a life coach is
how to be a life coach it's great
nothing talib is he's such a
[ __ ] man like he keeps on
calling out Jordan Peterson on Twitter
like hashtag Jordan Peterson as a
charlatan
like he just keeps up and then he'll tag
him I know just like I absolutely love
nothing talib but I feel like I feel
like he I've asked him to come on and he
said that he's towards the end of the
year he might have a little bit
him and God's art is well above because
it would both be cool he's one of those
guys who for me it was the same as when
I sat down with Jordan Hall people who
have that degree of understanding
sometimes I don't really get nervous
before doing podcasts anymore but Jordan
Hall I did and Nassim Taleb I did I
probably will do God sad I would
oddly enough Peterson I wouldn't and one
of the reasons is that I think that they
those guys occupy a very different
mental space to me and my I always know
that when I'm doing a podcast no matter
what happens as long as me and the
person that I'm talking to a kind of on
the same wavelength it doesn't really
matter how [ __ ] awry the conversation
goes can always just bring it back to
crack yeah like but how the [ __ ] do you
have crack with Nassim Taleb like the
big guy is a monster like they say but
navarre i'd feel like not cool like we'd
be on a level there'd be something that
I would be able to find it's a common
ground
yeah last time I told you five is he as
he less yeah okay well that'd be that
would be interesting to do but George
man today has been fantastic any
resources which we've quoted today I
know that we have gone through an awful
lot there's been some name dropping
below if we were able to tag all of the
people that had been mentioned in this
podcast I think it would be a it would
be longer than the tweets would allow at
George Mac m.a.c
on to Ma CK on Twitter on Twitter you
need to follow this guy they need to
tweet more you busy you can't tweet I
don't know button would be a Matt and it
would be a map guy that were just
talking about life and you're never
actually living it so with a zero-sum
game but didn't get on to that but like
times limited I do need to sweet more
but um but yeah it's been good fun man
thank you very much thank you so much
Matt it's been good fun awesome love it
[Music]
you